CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
consider the following problem.
The first part is I'd like
to know, for what values of b
is this vector field
F conservative?
And F is defined as y*i plus
the quantity x plus b*y*z j plus
the quantity y
squared plus 1, k.
So as you can see,
the only thing
we're allowed to
manipulate in this problem
is b. b will be
some real number.
And I want to know, what real
numbers can I put in for b so
that this vector
field is conservative.
The second part
of this problem is
for each b-value you
determined from one,
find a potential function.
So fix the b-value for one of
the ones that is acceptable,
based on number one, and then
find the potential function.
And then the third part
says that you should explain
why F dot dr is exact,
and this is obviously
for the b-values
determined from one.
So the second and third part
are once you know the b-values.
And you're only going to
use those b-values that
make F conservative, because
that's the place where we can
talk about finding a
potential function,
and that's where we can talk
about F dot dr being exact,
are exactly those values.
OK.
So why don't you pause the
video, work on these three
problems, and then when you're
feeling good about them,
bring the video back up,
I'll show you what I did.
OK, welcome back.
Again, we're interested in doing
three things with this vector
field.
The first thing we
want to do is to find
the values of b that make this
vector field conservative.
So I will start with that part.
And as we know from
the lecture, the thing
I ultimately need to do is I
need to find the curl of F. OK,
so the curl of F is going
to measure how far F
is from being conservative.
So if the curl of
F is 0, I'm going
to have F being conservative.
So that's really what I'm
interested in doing first.
So I'm actually just going
to rewrite what the curl of F
actually is.
So I'm going to let F-- I'm
going to denote in our usual
way by P, Q, R.
And in this case,
that's specifically y comma x
plus b*y*z comma y squared plus
1.
OK, that's my P, Q, R. So
P is y, Q is x plus b*y*z,
and R is y squared plus 1.
And now the curl of F-- which
was found in the lecture,
so I'm not going to show
you again how to find it,
I'm just going to write the
formula for it-- is exactly
the following vector.
It's the derivative of the R-th
component with respect to y,
minus the Q-th component
with respect to z.
That's the i-value.
The j-value is P sub
z minus R sub x, j.
The k-th value is Q
sub x minus P sub y, k.
OK, so there are
three components here.
And let's just start figuring
out what these values are,
and then we'll see what kind
of restrictions we have on b.
So let's start doing this.
So again, this is P,
this is Q, and this
is R. So R sub y is the
derivative of this component
with respect to y.
That's just 2y.
Q sub z is the derivative
of this with respect to z.
Well, this is 0,
and this is b*y.
OK.
Let's look at the rest first.
P sub z: the derivative of
this with respect to z is 0.
The derivative of R
with respect to x is 0.
So that doesn't have
any b's in it at all.
And then Q sub x minus P sub y.
Q is the middle one.
Q sub x is 1.
P is the first one.
P sub y is 1.
OK, so what do we get here?
I should have written
equals there, maybe.
OK, so the j-th component is 0.
And the k-th component is 0.
So all I'm left with
is 2y minus b*y, i.
And if I want F to
be conservative,
this quantity has
to be 0, so I see
there's only one b-value
that's going to work,
and that is b is equal to 2.
OK?
So I know in part one,
the answer to the question
is just for b equals
2, is F conservative.
That was, maybe, poorly phrased.
F is conservative
only when b is 2.
OK.
And that's because the curl
of F is 0 only when b is 2.
All right.
So now we can move on
to the second part.
And the second part is for
this particular value of b,
find a potential function.
And our strategy
for that is going
to be one of the
methods from lecture.
And it's going to be the
method from lecture that
in three dimensions is
much easier than the other.
So the one method in lecture
that's easy in three dimensions
is where you start
at the origin,
and you integrate F dot
dr along a curve that's
made up of line segments.
So this strategy I've done
before in two dimensions,
in one of the problems
in recitation.
Now, we'll see it
in three dimensions.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to integrate along
a certain curve F dot dr.
And this curve is going
to go from the origin to
(x_1, y_1, z_1).
And that will give us
f of (x_1, y_1, z_1).
OK.
So this is a sort
of general strategy,
and now we'll talk
about it specifically.
This will actually be f of
(x_1, y_1, z_1) plus a constant,
but we'll deal with that
part right at the end.
OK, so C in this case is going
to be made up of three curves.
And I'm going to draw
them, in a picture,
and then we're going
to describe them.
So I'm going to
start at (0, 0, 0).
My first curve will go
out to x_1 comma 0, 0,
and that's going to
be the curve C_1.
Oops.
I want that to go the other way.
That way.
OK, C_1 is going to go from
the origin to x_1 comma 0, 0.
So the y- and z-values
are going to be
0 and 0 all the way along, and
the x-value is going to change.
My next one-- I'm
going to make it long
so I can have enough
room to write-- that's
going to be my C_2.
And that's going to be
x_1 comma y_1 comma 0.
So in the end, what I've done
is I've taken my x-value,
I've kept it fixed all
the way along here,
but I'm varying the
y-value out to y_1.
And then the last one is
going to go straight up.
Right there.
And so it's going to be with
the x-value and y-value fixed.
And at the end, I will
be at x_1, y_1, z_1.
And this is C3.
So those are my three
curves-- And this one,
I'm going to move
in this direction.
Those are my three curves.
And I want to point
out that in order
to understand how to
simplify this problem,
I'm going to have to remind
myself what F dot dr is.
OK.
So F dot dr is P*dx
plus Q*dy plus R*dz.
Right?
That's what F dot dr is.
And so what I'm
interested in, I'm
going to integrate each of these
things along C_1, C_2, C_3.
But let's notice what
happens along certain numbers
of these curves.
If we come back over here.
On C_1, y is fixed
and z as fixed.
So dy and dz are both 0.
So on C1, I only have
to integrate P. OK,
so I'm going to
keep track of that.
On C_1-- which,
C_1 is parametrized
by x, 0 to x-- I
only need to worry
about the P. P of x, 0, 0, dx.
This is my C_1 component, and
there's nothing else there,
because these two are both 0.
Right?
Now let's consider
what happens on C_2.
If I look here.
On C_2, the x-value is fixed
and the z-value is fixed.
x is fixed at x_1
and z is fixed at 0.
And so dx and dz are both
0, because x and z are not
changing.
So there's only a dy component.
So on C_2, which is parametrized
in y-- from 0 to y_1--
I'm only interested in Q
at x_1 comma y comma 0, dy.
Again, this component is
0 on C_2 because dx is 0.
And this component is 0
on C_2 because dz is 0.
And this component--
I'm evaluating it--
x is fixed at x_1,
z is fixed at 0,
and the y is varying
from 0 to y1.
And then there's
one more component,
and I'm going to write
it below, and then
we'll do the rest over here.
And the third component
is the C_3 component.
Now, not surprisingly--
if I come back over here--
because x and y are fixed
all along the C3 component,
the only thing
that's changing is z.
So dx and dy are 0, so I'm
only worried about the dz part.
OK.
So again, as happened
before, I only
had P in the first one
and Q in the second one,
and now I have R,
only, in the third one.
And it's parametrized
in z, from 0 to z_1.
That's what z varies over.
And it's going to be R at
x_1 comma y_1 comma z dz.
Because the x's are fixed at
x_1, the y is fixed at y_1,
but z is varying from 0 to z_1.
All right.
So I have these
three parts, and now
I just have to fill them in with
the vector field that I have.
I want to find what
P is at (x, 0, 0),
what Q is at (x_1, y_1, 0),
and what R is at (x_1, y_1, z).
And then integrate.
So I have two steps left.
One is plugging in
and one is evaluating.
So let me remind us what P, Q,
and R actually are, and then
we'll see what we get.
Let me write it again.
Maybe here.
[P, Q, R] was equal to
y comma x plus 2y*z--
I'll put it here so you don't
have to look and I don't have
to look-- and then
y squared plus 1.
OK.
So P at x comma 0 comma 0.
Well, if I plug in
0 for y, P is 0.
So P at (x, 0, 0) is equal to 0.
So I get nothing to
integrate in the first part.
That's nice.
OK.
Now, what is Q at
x_1 comma y comma 0?
Well, that would be an x_1 here.
0 for y makes this term go away.
So it's just equal to x_1.
Right?
And then R at x_1 comma y_1
comma z is y_1 squared plus 1.
So now I'm going
to substitute these
into what I'm integrating.
So in the first one,
there's nothing there.
Let me just write it right here.
The Q is going to
be the integral
from 0 to y_1 of x_1 dy.
And the R part is going to
be the integral from 0 to z_1
of y_1 squared plus 1 dz.
OK, so the P part
was disappeared.
This is the Q part
evaluated where
I needed it to be evaluated.
It's just x_1 dy.
And the R part evaluated
at (x_1, y_1, z)
is just y_1 squared plus 1.
And so I integrate that in z.
So if I integrate this in y,
all I get is x_1*y evaluated 0
and y1.
So here I just get an x_1*y_1.
Right?
And then here, if I integrate
this in z, I just get a z--
and so I evaluate
that at z_1 and 0--
I just get z_1 times
y1 squared plus 1.
OK.
So this is actually
my potential function.
And so let me write it formally.
I should actually say,
this is my final answer.
Right?
I was integrating.
This is actually what I get.
And so what I was
trying to find,
if you remember-- I'm going
to come back here and just
mention it again.
What I was doing was I was
integrating along a curve F dot
dr, to give me f
of (x_1, y_1, z_1).
Right?
So now I've found it.
The only thing I said
is we also have to allow
for there to be a constant.
OK.
So the potential function is
actually exactly this function
plus a constant.
OK.
So this is f of (x_1, y_1, z_1).
And since I don't
have much room above,
I'll just write it below.
This is f of x_1, y_1, z_1.
So that's my potential function
for this vector field, capital
F, when it is conservative.
So when b is equal to 2.
OK, and there was one last
part to this question.
Right?
So if we come all
the way back over,
we're reminded of one last part.
It was explain why F dot dr
is exact for the b values
determined from number one.
And the reason is exactly
because of the following thing.
F is conservative based
on the fact that b is 2.
And so when we talk about
when F dot dr is exact,
the simplest case is
capital F is conservative,
and I'm on a simply
connected domain.
OK.
And if you notice, capital F is
defined for all values x, y, z,
and is differentiable for
all values of x, y, z.
So F is defined and
differentiable everywhere
on R^3.
R^3 is simply connected.
So we have a
conservative vector field
on a simply connected region.
And that's what it means.
That's one way that we have
of knowing F dot dr is exact.
And so that actually answers
the third part of the question.
So again, let me just
remind you what we did.
We started with
a vector field F,
we found values for b that made
that vector field conservative,
and then we used one
of the techniques
in class to find a potential
function for that value of b.
So there were a number
of steps involved,
but ultimately, again, it's
the same type of problem
you've seen before, when F was a
vector field in two dimensions.
So it shouldn't be feeling
too different from some
of the stuff you saw earlier.
OK, I think that's
where I'll stop.